it's crunch time for electoral
commission officials they're working
around the clock ahead of a general
election on Wednesday they have to make
sure voting materials get to their
destinations across the country on time
a tough task for a country roughly the
size of Western europeo the very last
item that Dennis Kadima is a president
of the independent National electoral
commission or seni his team was only
recently appointed and is working with a
tight budget and little time to prepare
the commission only has a fraction of
the 1.3 billion it says it needs to
carry out its work country is Big the
road are not good in addition to that
funding has been coming slowly and this
has resulted in us being unable to to to
uh send the goods by C we do almost
everything by air and that comes with a
huge cost some political candidates
petitioned the Constitutional Court to
postpone the election to allow more time
to sort out the logistics but the courts
ruled against that and the commission
says changing the election date is not
an option others say this is a familiar
problem the DRC seems to be a country
where people never learn from experience
so that we will have the same issues
coming over and over again as though you
know there is no way of coming out of of
the of of of the same situation all eyes
are on the Electoral commission voters
know it faces many challenges but they
want a free fair and credible vote
Katherine so Al jaaz kinasa Democratic
Republic of
Congo make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
zero